if men are becoming more abused nowadays
then we can see like
johnny depp
um we can see
and that's and i think sorry i just just
to kind of go somewhere else but i think
abuse isn't just physical as we already
said like what happened this year is is
drake
had to put hot sauce in his condom right
to stop himself to stop a woman getting
pregnant by him yeah that he didn't want
right right and so that's a form of
abuse
but really ask the question why are you
sleeping with that woman yeah yeah yeah
nobody
why would you if you could if you
speak one at a time speaking to the mic
please just the question
if you sleep with someone and you feel
that you have to put hot sauce
in your condom why are you sleeping but
the question is i just don't think women
face consequences i think that's why
like men are more abused because we
don't we don't face consequences for
doing it and just like this that's not
illegal for a girl to take a condom
and you might be like why would you
sleep with a girl like that but as a guy
he's a lottery ticket for a woman even
even he knows that though he knows
his position
and i think as a man when you're a a
catch or a prize man
you have the pick of the letter you can
choose anybody so should he say celibate
yes you will have not stopped no
no
as a man you should be disciplined and a
disciplined man can get far in life and
he doesn't he has to deal with a lot of
things he has to deal with a lot of
things and this is the problem she's not
so funny
this generation they kind of lack
discipline when it comes to certain
behaviors you say
you don't understand a man's nature you
know for you to say that you don't
really understand a man's nature because
um yeah when men like generally you know
this is all generally like no i'm saying
generally a man's nature yeah is to have
sex yes it's general nature but the
thing is when you get put in a position
of power
you as a woman would have no idea the
amount of
women that are coming for that man of
power as a matter of fact tiger woods
can be married all married men
regardless of how much power they hold
they've got a bunch of women that are
just looking to have sex with that man
and so
men
being men yeah in positions of power
sometimes
they say okay i'll take the option it
doesn't mean because you took the option
that you now have to have um in these
days and times you now have to have a
baby yeah well but he was he was
responsible too
he's right he used a condom he wore a
condom and and why why are we putting
this on the women or on the mat why
don't we put this on the women why are
we acting like home
like where are we why are we acting like
hoes why are you sleeping right so
basically what it is you're cause you're
confused by the thing so basically he
obviously ejaculating in the condom but
afterwards he put hot sauce in there to
basically kill the sperm and then threw
it in the trash but the woman
went in the trash took a condom out and
tried to push it inside of her and burnt
up her thing and had he not done that
she would have had a baby by him and he
would have said if you if you play it
out nine months down the line he would
have said there's no way that woman is
pregnant for my bit for reminding me
because i use a condom however
once she done the dna test it would have
had his dna and they would have said
drake you're talking lies because the
bottom line is she's got your dna but so
he would have looked like the liar yeah
because we had a conversation other day
was saying like women like to fight for
social justice right and eventually that
helps to change laws why do men not
stand up when things are happening to
them and speak up about it and have
those laws changed it should be illegal
for a woman to take a condom and shove
it up herself and have a baby it should
be
maybe it's because it's hard to prove
yeah
record
[Laughter]
as
women it's
it's innate in us for us to be able to
talk about
whatever it is you can sit around and
talk about someone you
talk about something with someone you've
known for maybe an hour five minutes
however it is as for men
it's not innate in them to be able to
sit down with their friends like hey yo
this this this this because
it's just
i don't i don't know it's just something
that has been
just shown like oh men shouldn't talk
mention and talk about this mentioning
gossip like women around the table but
they do though in private men have real
conversations with their boys about the
women that they're engaging with oh do
you know her oh i'm talking to this girl
blah blah they want their friends
opinions as well because if they're
dating a girl or linking her imagine
your boys are saying oh that girl's
clapped or she's nasty or whatever but
that's different from that's different
from talking about
issues a lot of men don't talk about the
issues that they have they can talk
about females all day talk about working
out this that in the third psychology no
you know justice is right because i went
to a
it was called
mantle actually it was in brixton and i
remember those
some professionals up there and they
were discussing about men issues
and it was only till i talked about my
issue
of
the mother not allowed me to see my
daughter the whole energy change in the
room and there was other men that came
up and started speaking even the two of
the panels that was talking about other
addictions and other issues that they
had didn't feed it upon themselves to
talk about how they seen their child or
the
parental alienation they were facing so
you're writing the zack in terms of what
jessica just said it's i've noticed even
from the back of as i said my podcast
and people have seen
a lot of fathers have reached out to me
that i was surprised and so wow i've
been going through this and they've
wanted to know what things to do
to actually start to see their children
it's you know what it's really deep um
it's a serious subject so i really again
have to say i appreciate your poem you
know sort of talking on it you know
what's interesting so
when i talk about a situation where the
woman is completely in the wrong right
there there's we no one on this panel
would say that the girl with the hot
sauce situation was in the right like we
all agree she was wrong
but we automatically put the blame onto
men and we say oh well you shouldn't be
dealing with that
but earlier when she was talking about a
situation
where she was in it like like he was
completely in the wrong nobody says oh
well you shouldn't have been dealing
with him exactly can i pause but yeah
when i went on the podcast
the amount of disgusting comments
that were written under that podcast i
was told that um
god is going to punish me and i chose to
open my legs and just all these
different things i chose the wrong man i
wanted this person that was like this
and
x y and z without actually understanding
the layers of the situation when i met
this person
i was 16. he was a good eight years
older than me
that in itself did not tell you
something
but for whatever reason i was getting
all these comments online at me
that
and again it comes to this whole
protection aspect the way i looked at it
was i was 16 and young and i was
in a situation where i felt like he was
protecting me
really he took advantage of the
situation and that is what led on to
whatever happened over the years but
when i went on the podcast what i found
quite disappointing was the fact that
i was attacked online
and
not many people in the comments stood up
for me and this is the issue i feel like
when women do come out and speak
so
it's okay for celebrities to speak but
when real people speak
it's like uh oh my gosh well you should
have seen the red flags and you should
have done this and you should have done
that well i i think it's just like a
level of accountability you know like
like the same way we were holding like
the manic like like to me that that's
the same but i don't think that's the
norm
i mean
just to say when you were speaking you
said you know you said celebrities and
then real people and that that concept
in people's mind that's what it is they
separate celebrities from real people
so when i said about drake
the reasons i said that is because he
already had a child in those similar
circumstances do you get what i mean so
him still um putting himself in a
position with oh no he put the hot sauce
yeah
i get that but you're still but the
thing is regardless of hot sauce or not
you're putting yourself in that position
furthermore the fact that the media has
it to talk about you're putting ideas in
people's heads you're actually putting
the idea out into the effort okay and i
find that why i should do that yeah i
think that a lot of these behaviors that
we're seeing with young women in
um young women and men is it's coming
from the fact that the media kind of
projects it into the space and
circulates it on a
a crazy hyper basis but can you imagine
the level of
paranoia
you have to be going through
every time you have sex as drake to
think damn did i put the hot sauce in a
condom this time do you know what i mean
and i think it's unfortunate that the
times in which we live in going back to
the book that i actually said talking
about how to destroy a man whether or
not
the fact that that book exists
i don't know how many women have read it
you don't know how many women have read
it
ish doesn't know how many people have
read it like we just don't know how many
women have read it so it's like
is it now time to protect ourselves well
you know what i think would stop a lot
of this if men could do a financial
abortion
women women have the right not to be a
parent
so so i think like a lot of these girls
are doing this because they're trying to
get a check
if so if that happened if there was a
financial abortion sorry speaking to
them please imagine if men could say
right yes i had sex with this woman but
i don't want to be responsible for the
child if there becomes a child
how many more single parents would they
well women do that they say i yes i
hooked up with this man but i don't want
to be a mom i'm going to kill it
they can do that up to six months he's
truly true
if we can if we can do that then [ __ ]
then he should be able to do the same
thing but the man and we shouldn't be
doing it
they're already doing it yeah but they
don't but that's what they're saying but
the man
you control having the child or not so
he can't do it he might get you pregnant
but you have the power to mm-hmm
exactly no i don't believe in that
statement i don't believe men get women
pregnant know what i mean
no it's 100 the fault of the woman if
you get pregnant if you get pregnant
that's on you as a woman 100 men
so i'll tell you how i'll explain how
i'll explain how so the first time i
heard that i was like
what do you mean but if you think about
it
who knows
when
you're like the time that you're fertile
yeah the woman does
sorry it's your job if you if you don't
want to get pregnant if you don't want
to um
if you don't want to get pregnant period
is your job to voice that to the man
and then if he and certain obviously in
certain situations there's
there's things that happen to where
a woman gets pregnant and
it wasn't
it was just a message
every woman is head of security for
their own vagina
every woman is head of security right
and the only the only if it's not a
great situation
you let somebody in
just like there's a door here
if it's not a burglar situation
someone let someone into this place and
hang on and hang on and the
responsibility for letting if you didn't
vet the person properly or if they
didn't show their id and you believed it
you look at the id that's on you because
once they run up in your house and
burgle your house that's going to be on
you
you have to be hang on but no but you
have to be head of security for your own
vagina and so if you keep letting men
who are not worthy up into your vagina
and shooting up your club that's your
that's on you iuds are more than 99
effective
get an id
yeah but then someone will argue not me
per se but someone will argue oh that
affects my hormones that fits my hair
[Music]
or whatever hormones you're putting into
your body affect your body
and that can affect you later on in life
than having a child
that
with the wrong person in a single parent
home yeah i would pick the iud i have
two children with a very wrong person
but i love my children
to the deaf of me and maybe not to the
deaf but i mean i love my children okay
and i think they're amazing people and
i'm grateful that i have the opportunity
to actually
raise my children in a different way and
some people may not agree with me stop
in contact but that is what i have to do
to be able to do that
and
i would rather have my children now
than be bleeding for the rest of my life
and in pain and having possibly other
complications in my body
just so that somebody
could well we're talking about
accidental pregnancy i'm not talking
about like the guy the choice between a
guy beating you and like
talking about the beat yeah but even
even the
actual having the child obviously it's
come from
um non-protected sex right so my point
is
i could have been protected and as well
it's like does that not show you how men
can be coercively abusive in the sense
of how many men have said how many men
have said let me just put a tip in
and they keep going
and how many women have said okay like
why are you telling me
you know what's happening like no i mean
i'm saying like that was a choice like
you don't have to deal with those guys
so
so
i'm saying like that's a choice you
don't have to deal with those guys like
so so that that's a personal choice
and another thing as well you see you
just you've just said it there you're
still in control that
understanding your circumstance you're
in control if he sees the children or
not if it was the other way around this
is why with this conversation we're
having today if you was like that
you're still in control